le blanchemaison bonjour heureux de vous
retrouver ce matin dans la matinale de
rtl france alors pourquoi cet embargo de
la cedeao sur le m la cedeao a pris des
décisions très très dur dimanche dernier
et je crois que ça s'explique par
l'attitude du colonel gaye tôt qu'on l'a
vu sur votre écran tout à l'heure lors
du premier coup d'état puisqu'il ya deux
coups d'état en août à 2020 dans le fond
la cedeao avait été assez compréhensive
et elle avait discuté avec la junte et
finalement été sorti cette date du 27
février 2000 22 donc le mois prochain
pour des élections et un retour à la
gouvernement civil et puis deuxième coup
d'état
en 2021 mai 2021 et là on a commencé à
entendre à mais c'est trop court comme
délai on n'aura pas le temps de faire
des réformes d'écrire une constitution
il nous faut peut-être un an de plus
mais qu'est ce que c'est qu'un an en
afrique s'est passé et puis finalement
ce que demande le colonel gâteau c'est
50 plus c'est à dire pas de retour à la
vie civile avant fin février
2026 c'est bien loin à 2026 est ce que
ne l'admets pas la cedeao les chefs
d'état en réalité des quinze pays des 15
états membres de la cedeao c'est que le
colonel keïta ce soit un petit peu moqué
d'eux et c'est vrai que autant en
afrique on n'a pas l'habitude de se
mêler des affaires intérieures des
voisins autant on aime bien qu'on écoute
les conseils des anciens notamment les
conseils des pères c'est à dire des
chefs d'état des pays voisins et là ça
dépasse qui s'est passé le colonel gaye
tend à sous-estimer la capacité de
réaction des quinze chefs d'état de
gouvernement de la cedeao et
contrairement à ce qu'on dit c'est pas
du tout l'afrique francophone uniquement
via le nigeria il ya des béria donc
c'est l'afrique de l'ouest qui
unanimement a très sévèrement
sanctionner la junte avec les mesures
que vous avez indiqué tout à l'heure on
n'ose pas parler cordon sanitaire ce
serait en effet une mauvaise
plaisanterie puisque le virus circule
lui aussi totalement librement dans
cette région malheureusement est ce que
claude cet embargo peut être suivies
d'effet
alors pour faire changer le colonel
guèye gaye tous deux d'avis probablement
pas parce que ce qu'il veut c'est rester
au pouvoir le plus longtemps possible
mais enfin il a il a ouvert a entrouvert
la porte en disant je suis prêt à
continuer à discuter avec la cedeao mais
la sauce ne se laissera pas faire ou
bien il promet des élections dans un
délai très court un an 18 mois ou bien
ces sanctions vont s'appliquer alors sur
sur le plan technique c'est très
difficile d'isoler un pays comme le mali
parce qu'il ya les frontières très très
très très longue c'est un pays
totalement enclavé et que ces frontières
sont totalement poreuse d'ailleurs c'est
bien ça le problème puisque la crise
sécuritaire qui date maintenant de neuf
ans est due au fait que les djihadistes
passe d'une fronde d'un pays à l'autre
tout à fait librement parce que les
frontières en réalité ne sont pas
physiquement matérialiser et ne peuvent
pas être gardés par par des troupes
peut-être des algériens filtre leurs
frontières au nord du mali mais pour le
reste les djihadistes circulent à peu
près librement donc effectivement les
produits pourront aussi sans doute
circuler librement mais surtout la
situation sécuritaire va encore se
dégrader et tous les trafiquants de 2,2
de tous ordres vont évidemment voir les
profits qu'ils peuvent faire dans une
situation de ce genre c'est pas en
réalité la population qui va en souffrir
bien que l'embargo et des exceptions
pour les produits de première nécessité
pour les pharmaceutiques notamment
électricité aussi les sens aussi et donc
à part cela évidemment la position de la
cedeao va probablement entraîner une
suspension toutes les aides
internationales
et c'est cet isolement justement claude
ça veut dire que le mali est en grande
difficulté
le mali est un des pays les plus pauvres
du monde totalement enclavé est en très
grande difficulté il était en difficulté
sécuritaire et économique politique
depuis neuf ans les difficultés sont
accrus en effet par l'entêtement en
réalité de la junte qui dit vouloir
faire des réformes mais qui ne fait pas
de réforme car ne sait pas comment faire
les réformes et c'est très difficile a
essayé de parler avec des représentants
des jihadistes elle essaie de parler aux
touaregs mais là aussi elles n'y
arrivent pas et par conséquent la
situation ne peut que se dégrader c'est
très embêtant parce que naturellement
c'est le sort de la population malienne
qui est en jeu aussi le sort d'un
certain nombre de soldats de la minus
marre des troupes de l'onu comment
vont-elles être ravitaillée des troupes
françaises puisqu'il en reste par kader
configurer et le commandement est à et
en dehors du mali il est à djamena mais
évidemment il ya là des considérations
qui font que probablement l'union
européenne va suivre la cedeao parce
qu'il ya pas de raison que l'union
européenne prenne une position
différente des pays qui sont dans la
région qui savent ce qu'il en est mieux
que tout autre et probablement maintenir
de l'aide humanitaire puisque l'aide
humanitaire c'est ce qui peut aider la
population à condition que la junte ne
prélève pas sa dîme au passage
merci beaucoup que pour toutes ces
précisions c'était l'édito diplo de la
matinale